salut je m'appelle famille honnie car
dans ce format nous faisons un focus sur
un point précis du cerveau dans
l'épisode précédent vous m'avez proposé
dans l'espace commentaires que l'on
aborde la fiabilité de nos perceptions
ça c'est le sujet du jour bienvenue dans
matière grise
[Musique]
plus
pour
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre cinq
expériences expérience une perspective
expérience de concentration expérience 3
silence expérience 4 tu l'as vu
expérience 5 touches sa douche pas le
tout avec la présence très appréciée de
marie alias angel phoenix ça fait
longtemps que voulait faire une vidéo
ensemble je suis vraiment ravi qu'elle
soit dans son interview numéro 2 bon
visionnage notre cerveau perçoit le
monde par les informations qui reçoit de
la vue de l'ouïe du goût de l'odorat du
toucher ses cinq sens sont complétées
par d'autres perceptions tels que la
proprioception qui fait que par exemple
vous pouvez vous vous toucher le bout du
nez les yeux fermés et je sais que ça
vous paraît pas très compliqué mais sans
ça on ne pourrait pas le faire
il ya également l'équilibré you ception
pas très simple à dire c'est ce qui fait
par exemple que vous savez que vous avez
le corps légèrement penché en avant ou
en arrière ou sur le côté
la nociception c'est le sens de la
douleur c'est cette perception là que
l'on reçoit est que l'on interprète
également la thermos et psion alors
thermos et psion terme aux températures
un bond à 10 et juste avant de passer à
l'expérience numéro une la perspective
je vous annonce que cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par moi même le fabien
olicard le fabien olicard est un artiste
pluridisciplinaire passionné par le
cerveau le mental mais aussi l'humour il
peut s'exprimer de différentes manières
équipé de la technologie five fingers il
peut écrire des livres comme
dernièrement votre temps et l'infini les
liens dans la description mais il est
également équipé de la technologie food
and feed qui permet dans la position
stand up à bord avant qu'au spectacle
qu'il pratique en tournée dans toute la
france comme ici ici ici
attention c'est la dernière tournée avec
la dernière date le 20 novembre 2009 un
zénith de paris
car oui pratiquer l'humour mais
également le mentalisme me fabien
olicard un artiste connaît très bien
lire son livre et voir son spectacle
depuis toujours nous cherchons à
comprendre notre réalité la question
c'est est-ce que nous doutons assez
d'elle pour les mentalistes la réponse
est non et nous jouons sur vos
perceptions pour transformer votre
réalité le temps d'un spectacle parce
que qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus subjectif
de plus personnel de plus intime que
notre perception et nos pensées
d'ailleurs est ce que vous comprenez
pourquoi ce dragon vous suit du regard
depuis tout à l'heure je vous le dis
très simplement c'est un simple dragon
en papier vous allez voir l'explication
est surprenante
donc aujourd'hui on parle des 5 sens et
d'abord je voulais te faire constater la
difficulté qu'on a parfois interprété la
perspective parce que je ne sais pas si
tu sais on apprend des choses dans cette
vidéo on a deux yeux et à cause de ses
deux yeux on voit en perspective on voit
en 3d ou que j'ai préparé des images je
vais te les faire voir ok et je vais te
poser des questions par rapport à elle
vous allez voir vous aussi ces images en
même temps à l'écran mais juste avant de
faire ça c'est mieux qu'une image c'est
une petite image découpée que je
voudrais te faire voir ne bouge pas je
vais l'installer ici c'est ce petit
dragon qui est là derrière nous ok ferme
les yeux et regarde loïc si vous les
yeux tu vois un dragon n'est ce pas oui
ok si tu bouges d'un pas sur la droite
est ce que tu vois son regard de suivre
vas-y oui est ce que tu peux bouger sur
la gauche de baisser te lever
est ce que tu peux confirmer que son
regard je suis tout le temps bah oui
mais tout temps c'est mona lisa est-ce
que c'est pas hyper bogans et ça c'est à
cause de tes deux yeux le seul truc
c'est que là vous pouvez peut-être vous
dire ok mais il ya quand même une
construction 3d et c'est peut-être aussi
pour ça que notre cerveau il agit comme
ça en fait non ça marche aussi sur du 2d
d'où ces petites feuilles mari est ce
que cette surface cette table est
identique à 70
je te pose la question en fait est ce
que cette table et galles cette table
charles millon qui a une mauvaise
réponse non ya pas de mauvaises en fait
je vais te dire non
je suis sûr que si tu fais ça c'est
parce que
l'illusion de chez part c'est celle qui
m'a vraiment encore aujourd'hui quand je
la vois qui me fait mal au cerveau il me
fait comprendre que nos perceptions ne
nous appartiennent pas qu'elles sont
traitées avant nous inconsciemment c'est
vraiment cette cette surface la blanche
est exactement la même que celle ci
s'est même pas la même surface c'est que
si les mêmes dimensions dans le même
ordre
ça rend fou pas on va découper on peut
le mettre dessus c'est exactement la
même chose que je cherchais des [ __ ]
je vais chercher des ciseaux je me
doutais que j'allais dire que ça je sais
que si je le fais pas même ceux qui nous
regardent dans la vidéo ne vont pas nous
croire je te laisse faire la comparaison
maintenant ça fait mal a énoncé que six
exactement la même taille c'est
exactement la même table ce point bleu
est à égale distance de lapointe que de
la base je vais plier évidemment au
niveau du point j'ai donc on constate
bien que le point est à égale distance
de la base que de la pointe
est ce que ça te plaît de constater ça
alors pourquoi notre cerveau se fait
avoir par la perspective et surtout
pourquoi quand on sait qu'il est en
train de se faire avoir et même la
raison il se fait quand même avoir alors
il ya plusieurs explications
la première c'est que malgré le fait que
notre cerveau utilise un tiers de son
fonctionnement pour la vue et pour le
traitement de ce qui perçoit par le sens
de la vue il est rempli d'habitude qui
sont elles mêmes liées à son expérience
et puis il faut pas oublier le fait
qu'on ait deux yeux ça je vous apprends
rien une nouvelle fois mais ses deux
yeux sont faits pour avoir une
représentation 3d de notre réalité
et puis quand même faut dire notre oeil
au site riche un petit peu notre oeil
il est fait pour mieux voir en largeur
que dans le sens de la hauteur et qu'en
est il de ces fameuses tables de chez
par alors l'étape de chez part elles
doivent leur nom de de chez par en fait
roger chez par le créateur c'est un
scientifique américain il a créé ces
tables là il a démontré sa en 1981
pourquoi ça produit cet effet sur nous
et déjà par la perspective également
parce que je ne vous expliquer par
rapport à l'oeil
et puis tout simplement parce que notre
cerveau interprète un dessin comme étant
une représentation en trois dimensions
au lieu de l'interpréter comme ce que
c'est à savoir un dessin en deux
dimensions
et qu'en est il de ce dragon pourquoi ça
fonctionne sur nous alors là c'est lié
aussi à nos souvenirs c'est à dire que
depuis toujours notre cerveau c'est
qu'un visage ça une forme convexe donc
il va vers l'extérieur parce que
vraiment si tu appuies tu vois que c'est
pas creux là mais le dragon qu'un simple
dragon en papier c'est une feuille de
papier pliée et qui est scotché de
l'autre côté ça donne ça on voit que le
visage et concave et même si je le sais
mon interprétation de ma perception elle
se fait avant d'être envoyé au conscient
et donc pour le cerveau encore une fois
c'est un visage donc c'est complexe
donc je vais le voir dans l'autre sens
et c'est pour ça que cette division
magnifique fonctionne d'ailleurs jeudi
un dragon depuis le départ mais en vrai
c'est un t-rex
tout est donc une question
d'interprétation et d'interprétation
entre autres des perspectives mais aussi
de concentration en parlant de
concentration est ce que vous avez vu
tous les changements qui est dans le
décor depuis le début de cette vidéo
non on va y revenir tout de suite parce
que c'est le thème de la prochaine
expérience expérience de la
concentration
[Musique]
je vous l'avais dit à quelques secondes
des choses allaient bouger dans le décor
je vous laisserai chercher il y avait il
y avait le personnage de léonard de
vinci
il y avait l'oeil qui est là-bas le
dragon faisait pas toujours la même
taille le cerveau posé sur la table
n'étaient pas dans le même sens
il ya plein de détails comme ça on verra
dans les commentaires si vous avez
trouvé on passe à trois maris pour la
concentration j'étais préparé des vidéos
juste pour aiguiser encore une fois ta
concentration alors la concentration
elle marche que si tu joues jeu de te
concentrer sur ce qu il faut se
concentrer
je te fais voir ses vidéos là peut-être
un as tu connais si tu les connais nous
le dit pas tout de suite parce que eux
les connaissent pas forcément ils vont
pouvoir les voir et si tu les connais à
la fin tu fais pas semblant de t'être
fait avoir il y vraiment il ya aucun
problème ok ok c'est parti donc tu
compte le nombre de passes de ces trois
personnes s'il te plait pas sa carrière
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux me dire le nombre de
pas s'il te plaît marie 10 ha ha ha mais
je les avais oui ok est ce que tu as vu
autre chose d'étrange sur cette vidéo et
je sais pas s'ils sont sur la même ligne
ou s'ils sont je sais pas comment j'ai
quelque chose qui va plus intéressé je
crois et qui va les intéresser également
est ce que tu vois ce panier de basket
ici ouais tu le vois là aussi la le
panier pas tellement à la patronne en
est ce que si je reviens avant dans la
vidéo tu le vois est ce qu'il est assez
visible pourtant
oui et doit juste le fait de se
concentrer sur le nombre de passes cette
image qui est vraiment pas très loin de
toi va commencer à s'effacer et tu ne
vas pas le prendre en considération
jusqu'à temps qu'il s'efface
complètement et que ton cerveau est
décidé à ta place que cette information
d'avoir un panier de basket qui dans la
vraie vie disparaît sous tes yeux
à quelques centimètres à peine de là où
tu regardes le ballon parce que je veux
dire on est sur une distance de aller 8
cm et bien ton cerveau a décidé dans le
traitement de la perception que ça
n'intéressait pas dire que vraiment
aurait pu être là dans la vraie vie et
ce truc disparaît là comme terreau des
préparé je vais pas te dire ce qu'il a à
faire
[Musique]
le
je sais qu'il n'a pas eue je sais pas ce
que même moi quand j'ai fait mes
recherches je me suis quand même fait
avoir et et tu sais pourquoi parce que
tu t'attends à ce qui se passe la balle
et comme il cela passe pas et qui
sautille au départ tu sais pas à quoi
t'attendre
et du coup que tu le veuilles ou non tu
apporter ta concentration sur qu'est ce
qui va se passer
tu vois et du coup qui t'es fait avoir
sur quelque chose est ce que tu as une
idée ou pas mais j'ai tout regardé au
début je pensais que c'était le ballon
qui allait disparaître
je sais pas est en fait après je me suis
en attend il saute sur place a peut-être
qu'il faut que je compte le nombre de
fois où eux-mêmes sous sa place et du
coup j'ai commencé à penser ça fait
perturbant du coup je sais non j'ai rien
vu en fait ça se passe ici au niveau des
toilettes elles ne sont pas apparus
elles n'ont pas non plus disparus par
contre elles ont vraiment changé de
couleur tu vois la couleur ici ouais bah
se produit tous aux couleurs de départ
en fait donc ça veut dire que sous tes
yeux alors que là tu t'attendais à ce
qui est un changement en plus il ya ce
truc qui a progressivement changé de
couleur pour ne plus être du tout dans
sa couleur d'origine et on s'est
vraiment garder cette info après c'est
quand même des couleurs proches sont pas
en bleu à anvers tu vois si on était
passé dans bleus un rouge peut-être ça
s'appelle de la dissonance cognitive tu
as envie d'avoir une explication très
logique qui justifie qu'on les paye mais
c'est bel est la preuve
[Musique]
le son que vous venez d'entendre
s'appelle de son de chez part à cause de
rejet chez par qui en 1964 tente un coup
il se dit je vais faire un son pur
électroniquement et donne une note
et puis se dit je vais travailler un
autre octave et pour que ce soit
vraiment très précis y prend pour la
deuxième note deux fois la fréquence de
la première note imx ça ensemble et ça
donne un son il l'appelle très
modestement le son de chez part il fait
ça ces mots sont en bois il dit mais on
peut peut-être aller plus loin il tente
une montée en gamme comme ça dénote ce
qui donne le son que vous avez entendu
cette montée en gamme
elle donne l'illusion quand on la remet
en boucle d'être une montée infini comme
un escalier qui ne s'arrêterait jamais
pourquoi parce que notre oreille va
s'accrocher à l'un des deux octaves en
permanence et nous donner cette illusion
que la note est toujours en train
d'augmenter alors que c'est faux elles
se répètent en boucle toutes les cette
note
écoutez très bien là écoutez écoutez
bien eu plus de quoi se sont c'est
exactement ce que vous avez entendu
précédemment en boucle je ne sais pas il
ya un truc à défrayer la chronique je ne
pouvais pas ne pas en parler danse
matière grise là quand on parlait de la
perception auditive
c'est un truc sur titi et gros minet tu
as vu passé c'est non pas leur
connectique hockey non mais c'est super
parce que comme ça pas mal tourné sur
twitter aussi bon peut-être je ne
l'utilisent pas grand bien lui fasse
ok c'est un tout petit extrait du
générique de titi et gros minet et tu
vas me dire ce que tu entends c'est à
dire qu'est ce que dit titi c'est parti
marie c'est à dire pas longtemps alors
il ya que ce que dit titi qui
m'intéresse ouvrez vos paupières le
hockey maintenant j'ai été faire écouter
un autre sens à des titis où il dit
ouvrez vos gros qu'on est bon bah c'est
sûr ça ok je te fais la suite maintenant
alors la suite
il faut juste que je vous explique un
petit peu les hallucinations auditives
justement c'est un truc qui pendant un
temps à une certaine mode sur internet
et mais comme cauet qui faisait des
vidéos dessus top 10 a fait des vidéos
dessus etc
mais le truc tu as envie de rétablir
quelque chose c'est que ça date d'il ya
plus longtemps et en 2009 2010 quand
j'ai commencé à paris je faisais les
cabarets il ya un mec un vieux de la
vieille maurice qui s'appelle serge
llado et son passage en cabaret c'était
ça donc il ya plus de dix ans serge
faisait déjà ça il faut faire je faisais
des assassins c'est une hallucination
auditive
en fait je les biens prononcé dans la
vraie vie c'est la perception qui est
pas bonne on le sait et on vient de le
prouver et à la radio il faisait ça
aussi dans une mission avec avec
il y avait des rues guerre il y avait
laurent wauquiez s'était on va pas se
gêner et j'ai retrouvé un des passages
de lui qui date d'il ya onze ans donc
comme ça c'est une preuve que lui
faisait ça avant tout le monde où il va
nous faire écouter des morceaux en
anglais et on va entendre autre chose
lui serge llado ils appellent ça des
hallucinations acoustique des salles
donc mais moi j'appelle ça la
destination auditive comme toi je te
fais écouter en fait son processus est
très simple et raconte une histoire en
fait on s'en fout l'histoire non en
français et à chaque fois c'est juste
pour meubler enrober le tout à chaque
fois il te dit et c'est là que untel est
arrivé au genre michael jackson est
arrivé et il a dit ceci cela là il te
met le passage et toi tu entends ou pas
le ceci cela qu'il avait dit juste avant
c'est moby qui l'a retrouvé à
l'intérieur de vie la baule et dans la
libye
discutait avec cheb mami qui lui n'avait
qu'une idée en tête aller manger un
cassoulet et roger carton et olivia
newton-john n'était pas du tout d'accord
si ça se trouve dans ton cas sous l'oeil
a du chien du poulet conclusion on à la
pâte la perception de la perspective bon
on peut pas s'y fier la perception de la
vue ou bon on peut pas s'y fier la
perception du son on peut pas s'y fier
est ce que tu es vraiment sûr de ta
réalité mari dans une réalité parallèle
donc c'est exactement situé dans la
petite je le savais je vous explique
pourquoi ça fonctionne assez rapidement
et on passe à la quatrième expérience on
revient un peu sur la vue et à la fin il
ya vraiment le touché et ça j'attends ça
avec impatience
arrête le par comme j'étais en train
d'expliquer à marie notre cerveau et
donc associatif et comparatifs donc dès
qu'il reçoit de la part de l'un des cinq
sens une perception quelconque avant de
l'envoyer au conscient il va le traiter
inconsciemment de son côté il va
fouiller dans tout ce qui connaît il va
comparer et il va chercher quelle est
leur accord le plus crédible à faire et
là par exemple par rapport au son si
vous n'êtes pas bilingue de naissance si
vous êtes à la basse français eh bien il
va se dire ok ça marche avec ça donc ça
doit dire ça en temps normal il envoie
sao conscients qu'ils y ok ça doit dire
ça mais là en l'occurrence qui se
passait quand serge suggère déjà une
information
ça rentre dans notre mémoire donc quand
il fait sa comparaison le cerveau y
compare d'abord à la dernière donnée qui
vient d'être rentrée qui est
effectivement la plus crédible c'est
pour ça qu'on suggère celle ci et on
l'entend tout de suite et ça fait une
petite question avant de passer à la
suite
est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce que
vous voyez là vous pouvez le dire à voix
haute ou dans votre tête ou dans les
commentaires qu est ce que vous voyez
ici comme représentation
voilà d'accord merci donc tous ceux qui
ont dit deux corps qui s'enlacent je
vous invite déjà à vous abonner à cette
chaîne
parce que c'est important de s'abonner
pour voir les prochains matière grise et
toutes les autres vidéos donc fait le
clic et ça prend pas longtemps si vous
l'êtes déjà activé la cloche parce que
j'ai pas de date de sortie de vidéos
donc
elle pop n'importe quand faut que vous
soyez prévenus et puis maintenant je
vais vous dire pourquoi vous vous êtes
trompé que c'est pas de corps qui
s'enlacent parce qu'on va passer à
l'expérience 4 par rapport à la vie
[Musique]
c'est avant on passait l'expérience cap
j'ai demandé aux gens ce qu'ils voyaient
ici parce que tu peux bien ce que tu
vois basile écrit on a déjà perdu la
monétisation autre cause de titi et gros
minet donc hors dia une petite position
sexuelle le kama sutra
oui donc en fait on voit 9 dauphin
surtout tu vois là il ya un dauphin il
ya un dauphin il ya un dauphin il ya un
dauphin il ya un dauphin il ya un
dauphin
si vous les voyez mal je voulais mais à
l'écran mais regarde juste les échos
lorient bleus comme ça c'est plus clair
en fait là où on arrive à avoir les gens
non pas parce que ces comparatifs 6 bien
sûr mais on a fait un beau retour en
blanc qui définit la forme et ces
éléments là ne font pas partie du truc
de dauphins ils sont vraiment là que
pour compléter le dessin était la
suggestion complète donc ça c'est une
bonne manière de t'avoir et de te faire
peur après mais c'est normal
rassure-toi 99% des gens en face de nous
on vu la même chose que toi des dauphins
c'est quelque chose que tu connais
sûrement qui a défrayé la chronique mais
c'est très intéressant d'en parler c'est
ça oh la la robe
alors on va pas passer milan dessus mais
toi tu la vois quelle couleur là par
exemple je l'avais adorée
enfin vous dorer grise ça en blanc
cassis
doré jaune ok c'est très intéressant
parce que moi là au moment où je te
parle je la voie bleue et noire
on relance le débat dans les
commentaires oui c'est possible ça
m'énerve parce qu'une petite parce qu'il
n'y a pas moyen en fait qu'est ce que tu
vois la comm daccords du bleu turquoise
moi je vois du moulin espèces de vers
turquoise mois s'attirant verte et du
gris gris ok toi aussi
ok ça me rassure là pour le coup on est
raccord des personnes ou voit cette
baskets roses rose marie ça oui plan
rose rose
alors en fait en réalité cette basket
d'ailleurs et rose dans la vraie vie ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de se dire encore
une fois c'est le sujet de cette vidéo
est ce que notre réalité c'est vraiment
la nôtre en fait c'est vraiment très
intime la perception de la réalité la
preuve
là on compare des choses qui sont assez
factuel mais combien de fois dans la vie
on voit les choses différemment des
autres tu vois je vais te faire voir des
assiettes et des tasses qui sont bombées
c'est qu'ils sont mises à l'envers ok ok
voilà qui sont bombées vernis est ce que
tu peux les regarder s'il te plait je
les vois bombay elles sont creuses tu
les a jamais vus bombe et tu les as vus
creuse direct creuse dommage ça fait
partie de ses illusions qu'on peut pas
marcher sur toi ah parce que j'étais
censé les voir quelques secondes pas
très longtemps sa part très très vite
je sais pas si vous ça vous la fais dit
moi dans les commentaires aussi qu'on
puisse voir la baule la proportion du
nombre de personnes une fois que les a
vus dans comme elles le sont vraiment à
savoir creuse tu peux plus les voir en
fait le fait qu'on te suggère juste
avant de le faire voir quelles sont
bombées ça peut t'aider à ça n'était pas
t'avoir comme ça maric et alors là par
contre d'explication elle est sympa de
pourquoi on peut le voir tomber si on
nous l'a suggéré c'est à cause des
ombres
on est toujours habitué à avoir l'ombre
qui vient avec la notion d'un soleil en
hauteur si si la lumière était au dessus
on devrait avoir des ombres ici plutôt
qu'ici sur le côté que tu vois parce
qu'en plus le même pas des tasses
des assiettes en papier c'est plus est
ce que tu veux l'explication de ça parce
que ça me renvoie sans plomb normal il
faut comprendre que dans notre
interprétation des choses le cerveau
prend en compte l'environnement en
permanence et ce que je parlais là pour
la lumière ça s'applique aussi ici et
ici en fait dans cerveau va se dire je
détermine si c'est de la lumière
d'intérieur ou de la lumière d'extérieur
et là je détermine si cette chaussure
est surexposé ou sous-exposés une fois
qu'il fait sa popote saute demander ton
avis du tout il fait ça balance des
couleurs et il réinterprète la couleur
sans que tu puisse le modifier
consciemment le meilleur exemple que
j'ai c'est cet échiquier qui sert à le
démontrer ou a et b ont exactement la
même couleur mais le fait qu'ils aient
septembre ici on a l'impression que
c'est pas exactement la même couleur qui
est nuances différentes alors que
vraiment c'est deux cases sont
exactement de la même couleur mais toi
tu as l'impression que celle ci est
beaucoup plus claire que celle là ouais
mais non c'est vraiment la même couleur
si on trace un chemin de leur couleur
commune entre deux on n'arrive plus à
voir la différence
je découpe b comme ça on le compare
directement bah oui on pense à vous
faisons ça j'essaie de le découper
propre comme ça on pourrait le remettre
à sa place après donc là c'est toujours
ce bella de tout à l'heure tu vois qui
est pour toi
très logiquement fait partie des cases
blanches ils agissent dans l'ombre du
verre mais forcément est pas la même
couleur que lui sauf si tu leur approche
et tu peux constater que c'est
exactement la même couleur sans aucune
nuance mais si je le remets ton cerveau
réinterprète l'ombre et réinterprète les
cases et voit cette couleur plus claire
que l'expérience 5 la dernière
expérience et celle qui me tient le plus
à coeur c'est l'expérience de la
perception du toucher et ça on n'est pas
habitué on est habitué à voir des
illusions d'optique en ont peut être un
tout petit peu habitués à se faire avoir
à l'audition et on peut être habitué
également à se faire avoir par la
perspective mais se faire avoir par le
toucher est ce que c'est le cas est ce
que vraiment vous l'avez déjà détecté on
va essayer de voir ça avec marie c'est
d'après moi avec le goût l'indécence les
plus personnels et les plus subjectif le
goût et le toucher ce que je leur disais
dans l'intro il me semble que c'est
presque le truc le plus personnel qu'on
partage le mois en fait et qui est le
plus dur à décrire
là je vais essayer de te faire vivre
autre chose ça marche dans la grande
majorité des cas au bureau il ya que
fanny cas pas réussi à avoir la
sensation
je prie pour que toi ça fonctionne je
veux sortir ça on va voir comment ton
cerveau va traiter l'information du
touch et touch ouazine be on se souvient
plus du don des billes avec marie on se
disait ça en off est ce que vous vous
souvenez de comment on appelle celle
lancée
oui si celle ci s'était pas les punir
les pirates étaient pas ça si on sait
juste que celle ci c'est des pépites
celle-ci cdpq moi je te crois je me suis
un peu aucun nom de billes en fait tu
vas faire comme ça et évidemment si vous
avez une bille chez vous
vous pouvez exactement faire la même
chose vous allez voir c'est intéressant
tu va croiser tes doigts comme ça et
effectivement tu le croises le plus
trash possible comme ça exact ok tu vas
positionné par au dessus pour tomber sur
la bi le but c'est que la bielle rentrer
en contact avec tu vois le côté de ce
doigt ici et avec le plat de l'index
donc tu tombe dessus comme ça tu sens le
point de contact sur les deux doigts tu
regardes pas et tu bouges légèrement
d'avant en arrière et de drague mais
très léger et tu vas continuer jusqu'à
temps de sentir comme une séparation
comme s'il y avait deux billes comme
s'il ya une bille différents nos vies ça
arrive et il sent comme un grand vide
entre les deux comme c'est incroyable
réponse théorique j'ai l'impression qu'à
tout moment jambes et doivent ont
séparés c'est fou hein
est-ce que c'est pas la première fois
que tu te fais brain sur le toucher en
faites quoi tu vas c'est un peu dingue
la même quand je sais quand tu regardes
ça le film revenir
c'est très bizarre mais c'est parce que
c'est parce que tes doigts sont pas dans
le même sens exactement à ses justes
pour en fait un truc de la
proprioception qui sait où sont chacun
des éléments de ton corps partout dans
l'espace
il n'est pas trop fait pour savoir
comment sont les doigts les uns par
rapport aux autres ce qui fait que si
toi tu sais consciemment que tu les as
croisé le cerveau ça veut rien dire pour
lui et donc quand il fait ça pour lui se
dit ok si je sens une bille la secal et
à droite de la main et si je sens une
ville assez calé à gauche de la main
donc là de billets c'est la seule
conclusion logique qu'ils aient à en
retirer en fait croyable changer l'âge
est clairement l'impression que georges
et 2be dans l'assassinât et que je suis
séparé les deux jours là je peux dire
allez c'est comme si je faisais ça ouais
c'est fou hein on passe à la prof chat
d'illusions à tous et marine
ce que laisse digéré sa 2e place il y en
a une dernière
ok donc ça c'est une expérience célèbre
mari sur les membres fantômes
ok je mettrai des biens dans la
description pour ceux qui veulent aller
plus loin par exemple il ya des gens qui
ont perdu leurs mains et qu'ils ont
l'impression d'avoir le poing serré en
permanence eh ben c'est avec ce genre
d'illusions de touche et qu'on peut leur
donner la sensation de desserrer une
bonne fois pour toutes leurs mains les
membres fantômes c'est terrible quand tu
ressens ça mais tu peux aussi avoir des
sensations similaires
quand tu en possession de tous ses
membres j'ai essayé de te faire salle à
qui ça peut mettre du temps à venir ça
peut ne jamais venir
c'est comme plein de choses en fait que
tu vois si ça vient pas battu me tiendra
au cours donc là tu as le bras gauche
qui exactement dans la même position que
cette main là c'est qu'ils m'offrent et
à krueger parce que j'ai trouvé que ça
mais tu vas devoir imaginer que cette
marche est la tienne
quand je vais donner des sensations à ta
vraie main et à cette fausse main en
même temps les mêmes sensations
toi tu va regarder que cette main et
intérieurement tu vas te dire que c'est
ta main et un moment donné tu vas
peut-être sentir que les sensations sont
déportés ici comme si tu avais
l'impression qu'elle venait de là alors
que tu sais évidemment que nous si ça si
ça arrive tu me dis wow ça commence à
venir ou un truc comme ça juste pour
qu'on fasse la comparaison ce match donc
c'est parti je commence
qui est vraiment tu dois te dire que ça
ça c'est ta main je tire des sensations
d'ailleurs différente parce que j'ai
prévu des petites plumes
en général plus on prend de temps et de
longueur et plus cela peut fonctionner
cette le fait un peu oui c'est ce qu'ils
aimeraient alors le c'est très
dérangeant c'est une preuve
et ça fonctionne et moi quand on me l'a
fait j'ai trouvé ça particulièrement
désagréable je ne ressens pas c'est
normal
en fait ce qui est terrible c'est que au
fur et à mesure que tu t'es dit d'accord
et mama imagine si on faisait ça s'est
terminé tu prends le tout est bien
c'est incroyable cette expérience elle
est incroyable je vous mettrais un lien
dans la discussion pour en savoir plus
c'est que une fois que tu as aussi que
les sensations reviennent de cette mam
et si tu sais que c'est faux quand tu
reçois le coup de marteau ton cerveau
mais tout en branle comme si tu l'avais
reçu et tu peux presque ressentir la
sensation et s'est coupé tout de suite
hein t'as pas de douleur mais c'est très
étrange et c'est fou c'est le oui c'est
complètement fou je contactais réussi à
vivre ça et le truc de la bille qui sont
deux choses en fait qui montre que même
notre perception du tout chez elle peu
sais pas quelle peut être manipulé c'est
qu'elle est déjà manipulé plein de fois
sans qu'on s'en rende compte et c'est ce
que tu viens d'avoir la main c'est ainsi
que va s'achever ce matière grise
j'espère que cette vidéo là vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à liker la
vidéo merci mille fois à marie d'avoir
pris toute sa journée pour venir tourner
ça avec nous parce que vraiment matière
grise ça prend du matin à 8h30 jusqu'à
la fin de journée 18 heures donc merci
beaucoup à elle je vous invite à la
suivre sur sa chaîne vous avez des liens
vers sa chaîne version instagram dans la
description vous avez également
l'opportunité incroyable de vous abonner
à ma chaîne par la même occasion et
d'activer la cloche ou de vous abonner à
mon instagram qui apparaît là également
je vous mettrais pour celles et ceux que
ça intéresse un petit peu plus de
ressources à l'intérieur de la
description quelques liens où vous
pouvez cliquer pour aller un petit peu
plus loin dans tout ça et pour celles et
ceux qui se posent la question le
prochain matière grise ce sera dans un
peu moins de deux mois parce que c'est
un format une fois tous les deux mois
pour les raisons que vous connaissez et
évidemment
alors est ce que la réalité est
quantifiable et objective ou est ce
qu'elle est forcément subjective est ce
que vous allez continuer à vous faire
avoir ou est ce que vous aviez constater
que le dragon était maintenant convexe
vous aurez la réponse à cette question
et à bien d'autres dans les prochains
épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao